[Music]
all right as we told you in tonight's
opening monologue new Pew Research poll
this is huge it comes to this alarming
collusion more Americans worried about
fake news and terrorism that's how much
distrust rightly exists the timing of
this book could not be any more perfect
is the author of the brand-new book it's
called unfreedom of the press it is now
number one two weeks in a row on the New
York Times bestseller list why because
it's full of history and substance in
other words a typical event book he's
the host to life liberty and Levin here
on the new Fox News Channel nationally
syndicated radio show host and he'd
never admit it publicly but a friend of
mine great one first of all there's a
reason all your books go to number one
because they're full of substance and I
read a cover to cover and I read your
book I look at this Pew Research poll
and I look at a president that has taken
on this corrupt media and to you plus
years of lying conspiracies and a hoax
how could anyone trust them well you
know Sean I'll tell you I wrote this
book because the media won't self police
there's no circumspection
there's no reconsideration there's no
shame and there really no standards left
so it's up to We the People to take a
look at the media since the media won't
look at each at themselves that wasn't
always the case I wrote down a few
things here problems with most of the
mass media today notice I don't call
them the Free Press because they don't
even understand what a free press is
supposed to be or the history of a press
because they're destroying a free press
they commingle news and opinion pseudo
events they manufacture events we spent
three days talking about the word nasty
how preposterous they push propaganda
for the progressive ideology aoc is
famous not because she's smart not
because she's profound not because she's
accomplished anything but because they
want to promote her and her agenda
social activism climate change is there
any individual at CNN or MSNBC in their
newsrooms who don't push climate change
there's no diversity of intellectual
thought in these newsroom
none they've abandoned the pursuit of
objectivity for social activism
progressivism and the Democrat Party
agenda and they promote that agenda day
in and day out
in fact they lead it the reason we talk
about impeachment today is not because
the president committed any impeachable
offenses it's because the media and the
Democrat Party want to remove him the
reason we spent two-and-a-half years
talking about collusion with Russia a
manufactured story a pseudo think event
as the president calls it not because
there was any evidence but because this
is what the media was pushing day in and
day out they are not defending the right
on the First Amendment of freedom of the
press what is the purpose of freedom of
the press why is it in the First
Amendment it's not in the First
Amendment because of CNN or MSNBC or
their corporate ownership or any
specific so-called journalist it's in
there for the American people now why do
we have freedom of the press we have
freedom of the press to expand freedom
of speech among the American people the
point of news and newsrooms is to give
us the information through which we can
make decisions about our families our
lives our government our country so we
can be informed the best place to find
it right now is local TV news you're not
going to find it in the vast majority of
news operations at the national level
mark well I disagree yeah you you get it
right rush gets it right I get it right
every news every single news room in
America fell for the lies the
conspiracies and the hoaxes you know we
have ed Henry and Katherine Harris Sean
I said those rooms newsrooms not talk
radio now the opinion shows and they
look down on all of us and the funny
thing is there is much opinion as the
rest of us the differences we're
transparent we tell people who we are we
don't pretend to be something that we're
not these people who are reporters today
not all of them there's some exceptions
but unfortunately the general rule they
don't understand the history of freedom
of the press they don't even understand
the value of freedom of the press most
of them are narcissistic most of them
draw attention to themselves want to
draw tensions than themselves I can go
down the list Acosta and so forth that's
not news that's not serving the American
people that's not freedom of the press
so the point I want to make to you is
this the President of the United States
is their target right now but overall
it's the American people the difference
between the patriot press was they
wanted to fundamentally transform
government the press today wants to
fundamentally protect it the praetorian
guard a big government and if you're
somebody from the outside and you want
to challenge it if you're somebody from
the outside and you want to limit it cut
it rearrange it you're the enemy of the
press they like to talk about the
president saying that they're the enemy
of the people but with the press has its
own enemies today the press wants to
fundamentally transform not government
but the American citizen but the civil
society or the difference between the
Patriot press and the press today it's a
disaster
all right great one on freedom of the
press but for weeks now amazon.com
between them in the New York Times
number one in the country well deserved
great job life liberty Lavin don't miss
it every Sunday the number one show on
cable right here on the Fox News Channel